So this week we're going to talk about,
um,
drug delivery.
And this is chapter 14.
So this is an example of what I call them,
the textbook biomolecular engineering.
And,
um,
this is one of my favorite weeks of the course because this is my,
uh,
my research specialty is drug delivery.
And so what I want to do,
um,
today,
Thursday and then we'll continue in section is today I'm going to sort of set up
a set up the problem,
talk about some definitions to think about if one,
it's building drug delivery systems,
think about some basic concepts in drug delivery.
And we're going to do that by,
by thinking about a sort of common modes of drug administration and why some of
them work with some drugs and not with others.
And,
uh,
so sort of lay the foundations today and then on,
um,
on Thursday we'll talk about what's new in drug delivery and what things you can
expect in the future,
things that are still being built.
And then you'll get to make some drug delivery systems in,
in section on Thursday afternoon.
So,
um,
this is really a logical extension of what we started talking about last week
when we moved from talking about the immune system and how it operates to,
uh,
to administration intentionally of vaccines to alter the immune system or to
change your body's response.
And in some senses you could think about delivery of a vaccine like delivery of
a drug.
We're introducing something not naturally in the body into the body in order to
have some kind of biological effect.
So it's the same thing as delivery of a drug.
And we,
and we also thought about delivery in a variety of ways.
We thought about,
uh,
injection of vaccines like the,
like the smallpox vaccine.
We thought about oral administration of vaccine in the case of the,
the,
uh,
oral polio vaccine.
And,
uh,
so I just wanted to show you this picture,
to remind you that you already know something about drug delivery.
What we're going to talk about is an extension of what we've started talking
about last week.
Now,
in the case of a vaccine,
you'll remember that the intent was to,
uh,
was to administer either proteins.
Usually proteins or whole viruses or we talked at the end of the class on
Thursday about administering DNA with the intention that you're going to bring
some new molecules into a special class of cells called antigen presenting
cells,
that those antigen presenting cells are going to be changed as a result of their
experience with this vaccine such that they present new molecules on their
surface.
That's the change that comes about.
And then that change in this cell is going to stimulate changes in other cells.
If a humoral immune response or an antibody mediated immune responses generated,
then the change in antigen presenting cells is going to influence B cells to
differentiate and proliferate,
et cetera.
So this is an example of a very particular example of what happens when you
administer a drug as well.
Chemicals are introduced into the body.
The intent is usually to make some kind of a biochemical change in cells or or
maybe many cells in your body such that their function is altered in some way
that's helpful to you.
And we didn't really talk about it last week,
but,
but in some cases immunization really is like drug delivery,
particularly in the case of what's called passive immunization,
where instead of introducing a pathogen or a piece of a pathogen to an
individual,
you actually make antibodies outside of the individual.
So manufacture them in some ways and we talked about ways of manufacturing
antibodies a few weeks ago and then introduce those antibodies themselves into
the person to provide protection against whatever pathogen those antibodies are
directed against.
And if any of you have traveled to areas of the world where hepatitis a is a
common and parts of Asia for example,
you might have gotten a shot of Gamma Globulin,
which is really just antibodies that are enriched for anti hepatitis a activity
now that the difference between that and a vaccine is that that dose of
antibodies only last for a certain length of time about 30 to 60 days.
So you have to get the shot 30 to 60 days before you're going to be in the area
where you're exposed.
And the same way,
we're going to think a lot about the timing of drugs.
How long did their affects last,
what determines how long they last,
and what does it mean if you still need the drug,
when it's effect is gone.
How does taking subsequent quantities of the drug effect its concentration in
your body,
for example.
So I'm going to start with some definitions and I realized that you can,
you can read this on your own and hopefully already have read some of this in
the,
in the chapter,
but just to make sure that we have the vocabulary right.
And some of these are words that you're familiar with,
like drug and a drug is any molecule which can be introduced into the body,
which alter his body function on a molecular level.
And so you're used to thinking about drugs you might take for a headache like
aspirin or Ibuprofen or if you have asthma for example,
you might take a,
you might take drugs that affect,
uh,
your bronchioles or the pathways,
the airways in your lung by dilating them.
So it's easier to get air in and out.
Um,
and so these are molecules which are introduced into the,
they make some kind of change in the body on a molecular level.
Pharmacology is the science of dealing with these interactions of molecules that
are introduced into the body.
Um,
and they're usually molecules that are generated from outside the body may be
synthesized in some way.
They might be molecules that are not ordinarily found in our bodies,
but are known to have some effects.
They might be derivatives of molecules that are naturally found in our bodies.
For example,
Parkinson's disease is treated by a derivative of the neurotransmitter dopamine.
And you're introducing something that looks very much like a natural molecule
back into the body to have an effect.
And toxicology is that branch of pharmacology that thinks exclusively about
toxic effects of the drug.
And one of the main challenges with developing drugs and drug delivery systems
is that drugs have unwanted effects,
right?
They have the effect that you desire at the tissue or within the cells,
uh,
that they were designed to affect.
But they can also have effects in other parts of the body.
And those effects are side effects,
right?
Those effects are toxicities or unwanted,
unwanted changes in the body as a result of the drug.
We're going to talk about two important,
different but related concepts called pharmacodynamics and pharmacokinetics.
Pharmacodynamics is the effect of a drug on a body and it's usually on the body
or on sales from the body and it's usually defined by a dose response curve.
Dose response means I give a certain amount of the drug and I see what effect it
has.
I give more.
I see what effect that has.
I see what effect that has and you can imagine that's a very important thing to
define for any drug because you want to deliver the minimum dose that's needed
to produce the desired effect,
right?
You don't want to introduce any more than necessary,
and so understanding the relationship between dose delivered and biological
response is very important.
Often that's done first on cells and culture.
For example,
you want to understand how a chemotherapy agent to potential agent for treating
tumors will affect tumors in a person.
The first thing you do is you might have some cultured tumor cells and you
expose those cells to different concentrations of the drug.
And you see at what dose do I begin to see cell death or killing of the tumor
cells.
That's one kind of dose response relationship.
Now you could understand probably that that might be very different if you
administer that same dose into a person.
And we're going to talk about why dose responses in people are different than
dose responses in cell cultures or in more artificial systems.
So the pharmacodynamic effect of a drug or,
or the study of pharmacodynamics is what does the drug do to the body and
usually as defined at specific doses.
What does it do?
Pharmacokinetics has to do with how your body handles the drug and the body has
exquisite mechanisms for getting rid of molecules.
Molecules that are produced naturally in your body only have a certain lifetime.
Likewise,
antibodies that we are molecules that we introduced from outside the body also
have a lifetime.
And that depends on the mechanism that your body uses to get rid of the
compound.
Well that,
um,
that manner in which the body handles a drug,
how the body changes the drug,
how it excretes the drug is called Pharmaco kinetics and that has to do with
what the body does to the drug,
not what the drug does to the body.
So that that's uh,
the easiest way to think about it.
One pharmaco kinetic concept that's very important is the concept of
bioavailability.
By have a dose of the drug,
let's say a hundred milligrams of a drug and I administer it to an individual,
then how much of that drug actually gets into the body where it can be useful
and bioavailability is going to depend on how we administer the drug if we
administer it orally versus injected intravenously versus some of the other
routes of administration.
We'll talk about in a few minutes.
The main effect of changing the route of administration is to change the
bioavailability or how much of the drug actually reaches the active sites.
A related concept is biotransformation,
biotransformation re it refers to all the mechanisms that your body could use to
convert a drug into something else.
And often that conversion of a drug into something else is an important part of
how your body gets rid of a drug.
And many biotransformation reactions happen in the liver.
The liver is a very active site of metabolism and chemical reaction and many
drugs that we take are converted into other compounds in the liver by cells in
the liver.
And often this conversion into another compound is the first step in your body
getting rid of it.
Sometimes it's the only step.
Sometimes your liver is able to convert a molecule into something that's
completely inactive,
right?
For example,
if you take alcohol,
which is a drug,
uh,
it's converted in the liver into other molecules which don't have the biological
effect of alcohol,
all right?
It's done by enzymes in our liver cells,
including the enzyme alcohol dehydrogenase.
Sometimes we won't talk so much about this,
but I want to to,
uh,
at least realize it,
is that sometimes we deliver molecules that are inactive.
They don't have any
response.
Your body doesn't have any response to them,
but we deliver them knowing that your liver is going to convert them into
something active,
that they're going to be bio transformed by some chemical reaction into an
active compound.
So it's another aspect of biotransformation.
Okay,
so I want to spend the next 15 or 20 minutes or so talking about how drugs are
administered and,
and in particular,
uh,
that question should be why are they administered in different,
in different ways.
Why is Ibuprofen,
uh,
taken orally for example,
but some antibiotics or chemotherapy drugs have to be injected directly into the
bloodstream.
So why is that do you think?
Why are some drugs administered in different ways?
Yeah,
it could be that you're targeting different parts of the body and so you want to
deliver them at their site of action.
That might be one w one reason to do it.
And they are,
what are you changing?
You're changing,
you're changing the potential for side effects really,
or the potential for toxicity of the drug.
Because if you can deliver more of it at the site of action,
um,
then,
uh,
then less of it goes to the rest of the body where it met cause unwanted
effects.
So that's a,
that's a very good reason to target it.
Yeah.
Sometimes there are biological barriers to drugs entering different parts of the
body.
Now we're going to start by talking about the body as sort of a single unit or
compartment.
And when I introduce drugs into them,
those drugs are available everywhere.
But that's not true.
And there are some parts of the body that are protected from entry of drugs and
the brain is the most famous of those,
of those parts of the body that are protected.
And it makes sense that the brain is protected because,
uh,
because are the function of the brain depends on the balance of chemical
concentrations within it.
The concentrations of ions and neurotransmitters and any molecules that could
potentially interfere with ions are neurotransmitters.
And so our brain chemistry has to be very tightly regulated in order for us to
stay awake and pay attention and do the things that we normally do.
In contrast,
the chemistry in our blood is changing throughout the day.
All right?
After you eat chemistry changes because molecules are absorbed from the,
from the intestine,
and as those molecules get processed,
the body concentration in the blood changes.
If your brain chemistry was changing in that same way,
right then you'd probably,
you'd be slipping in and out of consciousness and you notice that you do a
little bit right after lunch.
It's a little bit harder to pay attention then before a lodge because the
chemistry is changing,
but that change in chemistry is muted by the blood brain barrier or the fact
that molecules can't get very easily into the brain.
Okay.
Why,
why else might,
uh,
might drugs be administered in different ways?
Think about insulin.
What do you know about insulin
as a drug?
Yeah,
Kaitlin.
Speed of action isn't important,
is an important thing and we're going to talk in a few minutes about some drugs
were onset of action is very important.
It needs to act very quickly and the way that you administer it has a big effect
on how rapidly concentrations in the body rise.
And so some things you need to act very rapidly.
Uh,
you'll pick the motive administration to do that.
That's right.
There's another issue with insulin,
which,
which we'll come to keep that one in mind.
So this is a table,
but that's in the book.
And I want to go through it relatively quickly because I think,
uh,
you can,
you can read it and it's pretty understandable on its own.
But I,
I wanna I want to use these specific examples of different routes of
administration to think about the answer to this question.
Why are drugs administered in different ways?
And more importantly to think about the biology or the physiology of your body
that leads to these alternate forms of administration.
So one mode is intravenous injection and now we're going to talk,
there are different kinds of injection,
right?
You can put a needle into different parts of the body.
You can put it into a muscle,
you can put it under the skin.
You can put it actually into the spinal fluid that surrounds your,
that surrounds your spinal cord.
Uh,
intravenous injection refers specifically to a needle that's placed within the
bloodstream within a vein.
And so drugs are introduced directly into the bloodstream.
And the advantages of that should be obvious.
That's what was related to to Caitlin's comment.
That drug is immediately introduced into the blood and so it's immediately
distributed throughout your body and available for action wherever it's needed.
And so onset of action is very rapid.
In addition,
it's the bay bioavailability is 100%.
We've introduced the drug into the blood directly into your,
your circulatory flow.
And so all of the molecules that are administered to the patient are available
for action.
Now,
usually we were going to,
we think about bioavailability as the fraction of the drug that ends up in the
blood.
And you might say,
well,
but that might not be where the drug acts.
The drug might act in the brain or it might act in the kidney or it might act in
your muscles.
And being in the blood is not the same as being in those tissues.
And you're right that,
that's right.
Uh,
but,
but it's hard to measure those concentrations in individual tissues.
And so we defined bioavailability as the fraction of a drug dose that gets into
the blood.
Now why wouldn't we do intravenous administration for everything?
Because if it is fast,
usually you don't want to wait for,
you know,
you want the drug to act as rapidly as possible.
Um,
and,
and you'd like all the drug molecules to be bioavailable.
You don't like all of them to be useful.
So why don't we use intravenous administration all the time?
Well,
it probably is obvious that,
that,
that not,
uh,
that that is not so easy to do that in general,
a safe intravenous administration requires trained medical personnel.
So usually you're in a doctor's office or a hospital,
uh,
you,
you don't do it yourself at home.
And,
um,
and there is a risk because you're introducing drugs and high concentration into
the blood.
Uh,
there's,
there's much more risk of overdose or toxicity because the concentration is
going to change very rapidly.
And even though you might know what the average response to a drug is,
right?
Average among a population of people,
we're all different,
right?
We're all different in ways that are important to how Drugs Act,
And you know this,
if you take Ibuprofen,
you read the dosage on the label,
it will say something like if you're over 12 years old,
you take one dose and if you're under 12,
you take another dose,
right?
So size of the person or age of the person is an important determinant of how
much dose you take.
Gender is often important determinant,
right?
Your overall state of health is an important determinant and you can't know
those things for everybody,
right?
You could go on and on in this list and so you,
one individual might be more sensitive to doses of the drug than another.
If you're introducing all the drug at one time intravenously,
the potential for an unwanted response is higher.
It's a risk of infection because you're introducing something directly into the
bloodstream if it's not done properly and it's not comfortable,
right?
I mean,
not most people don't want to have an intravenous injection,
right?
And so,
uh,
you might not do it in cases where even if it would benefit you.
And so those are disadvantages,
right?
Um,
but it's,
it's,
uh,
but it's a very safe and effective and useful motive administration for some
kinds of compounds.
For example,
for antibiotics,
if you happen to have what's called sepsis or an infection that's spread into
your bloodstream,
one of the only ways to combat those infections effectively is to introduce
antibiotics directly into the bloodstream.
Intravenous infusion is a similar,
it's a similar mode,
but now instead of a onetime injection with an intravenous injection,
you have a syringe full of drug,
a needle in the,
in the,
in the circulatory system,
and you introduce the drug all at once in infusion,
you slowly pump the drug in and you might be pumping it in continuously over a
long period of time,
maybe over hours or over days.
And,
uh,
so sometimes this is done,
you've seen on TV shows,
you know,
a bag of a solution hanging up on,
uh,
on a,
on a pole and,
uh,
and a tube going into a patient's arm.
And so this is,
uh,
an infusion where the infusion is driven by the gravity flow of fluid through
the tube into the,
into,
um,
into the patient's blood vessel,
right?
That's one example of an infusion.
Other examples are there might be a pump involved.
At some point you have a pump in between the bag of fluid and the,
and the needle that goes into the arm.
And in this way you can control the flow much more carefully,
right?
You can control the flow much more carefully.
So one example of where that's done in the hospital is the molecule Heparin,
which is an anticoagulant and it's needed for,
um,
for certain patients who are at risk of having blood clots,
for example.
And this might be um,
um,
they might be at risk for blood clots for a variety of reasons,
but you introduced the molecule Heparin,
which reduces the likelihood that clots will form only.
You need to have a continuous level of Heparin.
You need to have that Heprin concentration continuously at some level.
And so you continuously infuse it directly into the,
into the,
um,
into the circulatory system.
Now this is a very effective method for administering drugs because you're
slowly adding the drug and you're watching to see what concentration is
maintained in the person and you're adjusting the rate by,
by tuning the pump until you get exactly the concentration that you want.
All right?
And then you can leave it there and as long as the patient stays roughly the
same,
then their concentration will remain roughly the same.
And so you can expose them to a drug over a long period of time and have a
biological effect that's constant over a long period of time.
And that's,
that's very useful in certain situations.
Like this one I've mentioned,
again,
it's 100% bio available and you have continuous control over plasma levels.
For example,
what if you knew that the patient was more at risk of developing blood clots at
night?
Well then you'd put a programmable pump on it and you'd program the pumps so
that the rate of infusion increased during the night and then went down again in
the morning.
And in that way,
you could increase the concentration of drug at night and then decrease it,
uh,
during the day.
And so you'd only be using the amount of drug that was needed for a biological
effect.
And you'd be adjusting that biological effect for the needs of the patient in a
very sort of interactive way.
And you can imagine now extending that very simple approach with a needle in the
bloodstream and a pump and a reservoir of fluid,
uh,
to deliver any pattern of drug that was needed for that individual.
Okay.
So what's,
what,
why isn't that done all the time?
Well,
for the same reasons that intravenous infusion aren't done all the time plus
some because this is even more complex,
right?
And so it requires continuous monitoring.
And so there have to be people there in case there is some unexpected event,
uh,
in order to turn off the pump or to adjust the flow.
And so that really requires hospitalization in most cases.
Now we're going to get the point next time we talk about some examples of
infusion using pumps that can be,
uh,
that can be worn by individuals.
They can leave the hospital with these pumps either implanted within them or uh,
or,
or strapped to their belt for example.
But in general,
that's done only in unusual situations.
Subcutaneous injection and intramuscular injection are similar to intravenous
injection and that it's an injection from a needle.
It's a onetime introduce all the drug at once,
but you're putting the needle in a different place instead of intentionally
putting the needle into,
into a vein so that you introduced drug into the blood.
You put it either in a muscle,
right and you could feel like a muscle mass of your arm,
uh,
or um,
or,
or your backside if you've ever had an injection there.
They don't do this so commonly anymore.
I'm not sure why,
but I can imagine why but,
but um,
but uh,
in,
into a,
a muscle mass and then the molecules are absorbed from that muscle into the
blood or subcutaneously is subcutaneous cutaneous.
The skin sub is under.
This is an injection under the skin.
And so you could pull up on your skin a little flap.
You can sort of pull it away from the muscle and you'd insert the needle under
there and introduce a little reservoir of a drug solution underneath the skin.
Um,
now this is how a diabetics administer insulin to themselves.
Usually they put a needle into the muscle and they inject a,
um,
a,
uh,
a volume of an insulin containing solution into the muscle space.
I say on this sheet here,
that bio availability in that case is usually high.
Why is it,
why do you think bio Avila be able to be as high bioavailability is high for
these,
uh,
particular modes?
Why is it high for intermuscular injection?
And it might be 80% or 90%.
So it's not a hundred,
but it's pretty high.
Why is that?
How does the drug get into the blood from there?
If I injected into muscle,
Justin?
Yeah,
so,
so your muscle is being perfused by blood all the time,
right?
It gets blood flow.
There's,
there's arteries going in,
capillary networks and veins that are collecting blood.
So there's a very rich blood supply in muscle.
And so you injected into the muscle tissue and the drug just sort of percolates
in or diffuses in to the blood vessels that are already there.
Now,
the effects tend to last longer than an intravenous administration because it
takes some time for the drugs to move from this reservoir where you've injected
them,
this little depot in the muscle,
it takes some time for the drugs to move into your bloodstream,
right?
And so you get a prolonged effect because of that,
not all of the drug is available at once.
You also don't get all the drug in because some of it is metabolized locally or
it doesn't go into the blood vessels at all.
And so it doesn't get distributed.
So bioavailability is not 100%,
but it's often pretty high and it's not as hazardous because you're not actually
introducing a needle into a vein.
It can be done,
uh,
by,
um,
uh,
individuals at home.
And so diabetics can do this,
they can do it several times a day.
Um,
and,
uh,
but it's still uncomfortable and most people don't want to do it.
And you wouldn't do it if there was an alternative.
Right?
So why is there no alternative for insulin?
Why,
why do diabetics do it this way?
Why did they inject insulin in this way?
And I think most of you could understand that they would prefer not,
but would they prefer to do?
If you were a diabetic patient and you needed insulin,
what would you prefer to do?
Kate,
you prefer to take a pill,
right?
You prefer to take a pill.
And that's the next one on the list is,
is oral.
Um,
uh,
administration.
You prefer to take a pill but you can't with insulin because insulin is a
protein.
Insulin is a protein that is digested in the,
uh,
in the intestinal tract.
And that's one of the functions of our,
of our gut is to digest foods that we,
that we eat foods that contain proteins for example.
And so your,
your intestinal system is very efficient at breaking down proteins into their
constituent amino acids.
And it does that so that you can extract amino acids from food and use them for
other things.
If the,
if a protein is a drug,
you need it to enter the bloodstream without being broken down.
When it's broken down,
it doesn't have the effect any longer.
And so insulin can't be delivered orally,
primarily because it's digested,
uh,
within the stomach and small intestine before it's absorbed.
Um,
another problem with,
uh,
with developing a pill or oral forms of insulin is that large molecules like
insulin,
which is a protein,
has a molecular weight of about 5,000 are not absorbed very easily through the
intestinal wall.
And we talked about this several weeks ago.
Your intestinal wall is a,
it's a tube,
it's a tube that the surface of the tube is made up of a continuous sheet or
monolayer of cells.
And these cells are connected by tight junctions.
Remember that picture I showed you several weeks ago,
and because of that,
for a molecule to enter,
it has to be able to go through that monolayer of cells.
So even if insulin wasn't broken down to its constituent molecules,
it couldn't be absorbed very easily because it's a large molecule and only
molecules that are small and relatively lipid soluble can go through monolayers
of cells like the epithelium of the intestine,
right?
So there's two reasons why insulin is not very bioavailable when it's given
orally,
right?
And that's one way of saying insulin doesn't end up in the blood,
Insulin is not bioavailable when delivered orally.
Some drugs are aspirin,
Acetaminophen,
Ibuprofen,
things that you might take routinely for muscle aches or headaches are,
are available orally.
They're small molecules.
They aren't,
they aren't digested appreciably or only a fraction of them are,
are,
are digested so that if you take 10 milligrams,
maybe five milligrams of them are not broken down in the gut and can be
absorbed,
right?
So,
uh,
one of the problems with oral administration is that drugs are degraded before
they're absorbed into the body.
Now we could tolerate that with aspirin.
And why do you think that's acceptable with aspirin?
To have some fraction of it broken down in the body,
broken down in the gut before it's absorbed.
Why is that acceptable?
How much does aspirin cost?
Not very much.
You don't think about it when you go buy a yellow,
a couple of tablets of aspirin or you go buy a bottle of aspirin or Ibuprofen
because it,
it costs something,
but it doesn't cost so much.
And so if you had to pay two times as much because you lost half of it because
it was degraded before it got absorbed,
that might be okay,
right?
Because you're more likely to use it because it's a pill and not an injection
and you're willing to pay more for that convenience.
Right?
And so often,
uh,
drugs that are orally administered,
they're not a hundred percent bio available,
only a fraction of it gets into your blood,
but they're molecules that can be produced cheaply enough that you can still
take a,
a dose that's larger than what you would need.
Knowing that half of it is not going to enter your body.
All right.
Does that make sense?
Uh,
the other thing about about aspirin is that,
um,
it's,
it's an,
it's not aspirin.
I'll use aspirin as an example,
realizing that nobody uses aspirin for headaches anymore.
But,
uh,
but,
it's a,
it's a good example because it's a molecule that's very safe and a safe drug is
one in which the concentration at which it causes toxic effects is much higher
than the concentration at which it causes good effects or the effect that you
want.
So we know an aspirin that if you get your concentration up to a certain level,
your headache will go away.
You'd have to get a much higher level in your blood before you began to see side
effects or unwanted effects.
And in,
um,
in aspirin,
those side effects are that your ears start to ring because it starts to affect,
uh,
the,
um,
your mechanisms of hearing the cells within your,
within your cochlea start to be affected by concentrations of the drug at a
certain level.
But you have to take a lot in order to get up there,
right?
So this difference between an effective dose and a toxic dose is very important
for,
uh,
for drugs and drugs that have a big difference between the safe dose and the
effective dose are ones that you can give to patients and trust them to take
safely.
You can imagine if the toxic dose was very close to the effective dose,
that might not be a drug that you would want to have patients administering
themselves.
Because what if they accidentally take one too many pills or they take them too
close together?
Right?
They could produce toxic side effects.
So aspirin is an example where you have a big window between effective and toxic
chemotherapy.
Drugs are drugs where there's a very narrow window between effective and toxic.
And so those are usually given with the,
um,
with the help and guidance of a physician.
Okay.
Um,
there's a similar motive administration called a sublingual or buckle.
And here,
um,
here the drug is not swallowed.
It's taken in the mouth,
but it's,
but you,
you hold the pill or the capsule underneath your tongue and you allow it to
dissolve there.
And so the drug is enters your body because it's absorbed through the membranes
in your mouth,
particularly the membranes under your tongue.
And this is a common mode of administration for Nitroglycerin.
If you have grandparents or,
or,
or friends who are older and have certain kinds of heart disease where they get
chest pain,
they might carry with them tablets of Nitroglycerin.
And if they begin to experience pain,
they'll put one of these tablets underneath their tongue and they'll let it
dissolve.
And there's a number of reasons for doing this.
And the most important one is that,
um,
when,
when you're taking a drug orally,
you're taking advantage of the mechanisms that your body has for getting food
and nutrients and you're using those mechanisms to get a drug.
When you're,
when,
when molecules are absorbed through your intestine,
they,
uh,
they go through the intestinal wall,
they enter the blood stream that surrounds the intestine,
and then the way that your anatomy is set up,
all of the blood flow from your intestine goes directly to your liver.
It goes directly to your liver and from your liver.
It goes back into the Vena Cava and then to the heart.
Now why,
why would you design a system like that where all the blood from your intestine
goes right to your liver?
First,
Justin
purifying and processing of the stuff that comes from the intestine,
stuff like food,
nutrients that are extracted from food,
sugars,
fats,
proteins,
right,
that are extracted from food that goes to your liver.
Why do they go to your liver?
Because your liver is a very important metabolic organ and it is important for
processing proteins and fats and sugars.
And so by sending all those molecules that are absorbed from the intestine into
the liver,
first,
you get,
uh,
you a jumpstart on processing of these molecules into the substrates that you
need for life,
right?
So that's a really good setup for nutrition.
But I also mentioned,
remember that biotransformation or breakdown of drugs often occurs in the liver.
And so if drugs are absorbed the same way that food is,
they go right to the liver.
And I'm pointing here because that's where my liver is,
right?
They go right to the liver and your liver starts to break it down right away
before it even gets to your bloodstream really,
before it circulates to the rest of your body.
And so I lose a fraction of drug because it's degraded within the gut.
I lose a fraction because it can't absorb very rapidly and I lose another
fraction because the liver breaks it down before it ever gets back to my heart.
Right?
And then your heart can circulate it.
Well,
it turns out that the blood supply to the,
to the membranes in your mouth don't go to the liver.
It's,
it's unusual.
They go directly into the superior Vena Cava and into your heart.
And so drug molecules that are absorbed in your mouth bypass the liver and they
go directly to your,
the rest of your body first.
And then of course,
they're going to end up in the liver as things get circulated around,
but they avoid going to deliver the first time.
And that's called here on this graph,
avoiding first pass metabolism in the liver.
This metabolism that occurs on the first shot right from the intestine is called
first pass metabolism.
Nitroglycerin would be very readily broken down in the liver and so this way it
goes directly to the heart without ever having to pass through the liver and it
can,
it can quickly treat heart disease.
Now,
why don't you do that with all sorts of things?
Uh,
well,
uh,
it only works for certain kinds of compounds,
compounds that can be absorbed through those membranes in your mouth.
So they have to be very lipid soluble.
They also have to be very potent because one difference between your mouth and
the intestine is that the surface area in your mouth is fairly small,
right?
The surface area in your mouth is fairly small and so only a limited number of
drugs can absorb through.
Whereas why is your intestine so long?
You know,
that your intestinal says he took it out and stretched it out.
It would be a two,
but continuous tube that's about 30 feet long.
Why is your intestine that long packed into this small space so that it can have
a big surface area to absorb?
Lots of stuff.
All right.
Big surface area,
lots of absorption,
small surface area,
little absorption.
So it has to be a very potent drug in order to be absorbed at a sufficient
concentration through this,
uh,
through this limited space.
So I think those are the main concepts that I wanted to introduce by thinking
about these different methods of administration.
There's more of them listed here.
Um,
some of them have to do with what,
what,
what Kaitlin mentioned,
if you want,
if you want a drug that works in the eye,
for example,
a drug to treat glaucoma,
why take a drug orally and,
and expose your whole body to the drug when you could just put drops in your eye
directly.
And that's how many glaucoma drugs are delivered.
You might have eyedrops that you just put into the space underneath your eye,
for example.
Right.
And that's a more targeted delivery targeted because you are putting the drug at
the site where it's needed.
I'm sure you have examples of that.
You know,
topical ointments like a antibacterial cream that you might put on something.
If you have a cut and you want to keep it from being infected,
you don't take antibiotics by mouth and have them all over your body.
You put a little topical treatment on the site because you're targeting the drug
to the site that you need.
Okay.
And on the next slide,
there's some other more uncommon modes of administration.
Um,
rectal,
transdermal vaginal.
We won't talk very much about those.
Um,
but now and next week we'll talk about a special kinds of drug delivery systems
that are useful for certain kinds of administration.
Um,
like,
um,
what are called controlled release implants.
We'll talk about next time.
Okay.
But I want to,
I,
I've given you a lot of words and I've tried to introduce a lot of concepts by
thinking about things that you know about.
I want to try to put this in some framework that allows you to think about a
quantitatively what it means,
what these factors mean.
And so we're going to introduce drugs into a patient.
And what we would like to know is how rapidly do those drugs become available,
what fraction of the drugs become available,
and how long does the one dose we give last?
And as I mentioned,
that's complicated,
right?
Complicated because our anatomy is complicated and complicated because we're all
different individuals and our anatomy and physiology differs.
And so it's a hard thing to do to describe how even one particular kind of drug
acts in a population of people is difficult.
And so we have to start somewhere.
So we're going to start with a simplification.
And that simplification is that these complex things people can be represented
by very simple
constructs.
And the simple construct that I show here is that instead of a person,
we're going to consider the person to be a well stirred vat of liquid water,
for example.
Now how can,
how can you get away with that?
Well,
one way to say we can get away with it is that we are mostly water,
right?
Our bodies are 90 water.
And so,
and so if you wanted to describe us sort of in the simplest possible way,
we're water.
That's largely what we are.
We're structured water.
We've watered with a particular kind of shape and form,
but we're largely water.
And so we could describe where drugs go in the body by just thinking about how
they dissolve in water.
And all you'd need to know is what's the volume of the water.
So if I give a dose,
what concentration do you get?
I give 10 milligrams.
If your volume is five liters,
what's the concentration you achieve inside?
What did I say?
10 milligrams?
I forgot what number I said.
No,
10 milligrams divided by five liters,
two milligrams per liter.
That's the concentration.
And uh,
that,
that's the simplest way to define it.
Now how can I get away with saying that we're well stirred and I indicate that
in this,
in this simple drawing by having a,
this is a propeller,
that stirring the VAT of liquid.
How can I get away with saying we're well stirred?
Well,
in some senses we are.
That's what our circulatory system does.
And I'm going to talk about that in,
um,
in the weeks to come.
But our heart is a very effective,
uh,
our heart and our blood vessels are very effective system for distributing
molecules very rapidly throughout a large volume.
And so we are,
uh,
we are stirred,
we are well stirred in certain senses.
Now you could object to this simple model for lots of different reasons,
but we're going to start with it because it's a very simple place to start.
And we're going to say then that we admit when we administer a drug,
we're introducing a drug into this well stirred that of water that has a
particular volume and we're going to administer some dos and we're going to
produce some concentration.
And now what happens afterwards?
Does that concentration stay the same forever?
No,
it,
it doesn't because we,
our body has mechanisms for getting rid of drugs.
And we're going to describe that in our simple model by having an Arrow pointing
out that tells you how,
um,
how that tells you that drugs are eliminated when they're within your body.
And we're going to make this a very simple process.
Also and say that drugs are eliminated in proportion to their concentration
in proportion to their concentrations.
So the more drug you have,
the faster it gets eliminated and as you have less and less drug,
it gets eliminated more slowly.
Now this,
uh,
this,
the simplest way to describe this is to say that the rate
okay
of disappearance
of a drug is equal to some constant times the concentration,
the rate of disappearance of a drug is equal to some constant times the
concentration.
And this constant is called a constant.
And this is the concentration that would be within the body,
right?
This is a first order equation,
It means that the rate at which the drug is eliminated is proportional to
concentration to the first power or linear with concentration as drug
concentration goes down.
SinceK is a constant for any particular drug,
it's,
it's one number.
As the concentration drops from two milligrams per liter to one milligram per
liter,
the rate that your body eliminates it goes down by half as well.
I like to think about this as as um,
uh,
you could think about concentration as money in your wallet,
right?
And the rate at which I spend money anyway is proportional to the amount that I
have in my wallet as like when I have more,
I spend more.
When I have less,
I spend less.
And the last dollar goes very slowly,
right?
The same thing here.
When you have a lot of concentration,
it gives your body,
gets rid of it fast and but the last molecules go out very slowly.
Okay.
If we take this simple model and then apply it and we introduced a dose directly
into the body.
Now this well stirred vat and we say that it has some volume and we say that
drug is eliminated with some rate constant k we could derive a simple equation
and this is derived in the book,
in the,
in the box at the back of the chapter that would tell us how concentration
varies with time.
And that equation is shown here.
The concentration is equal to the dose that I introduced,
which is m sub zero time divided by the volume of the body,
times e to the minus Kt,
whereK is this rate constant for disappearance of the drug.
Now if you don't understand,
when you look at the book where this equation comes from,
it,
that's not important.
Some of you will and some of you won't.
Uh,
but you could trust me that,
uh,
that this is the equation that results from those simple assumptions that I
talked about.
So c is the concentration that's available in your bloodstream or in this vat of
fluid that's available for action.
And M zero is the amount that's introduced.
And remember,
I introduced it in a special way.
I injected it right into the body.
I injected it all into the body,
the whole dose at time t equals zero.
I introduced it all into the body at once.
So it was all available to circulate.
That assumes the bioavailability is 100% and that I've introduced it all at one
particular time.
Right?
So what is this really a representation of?
It's a representation of intravenous injection where I have a syringe and I
inject all of the drug at once.
And in that case,
what this equation tells you is that the concentration immediately after you
inject the drug is the highest and after that it continually goes down and it
goes down in an exponential fashion with a,
with a,
um,
with a time course.
That depends on this constant k.
Now does that make sense?
If I have intravenous administration of a drug that's eliminated by a first
order process,
as soon as I administer it,
the concentration is a peak and after that it goes down and the rate at which it
goes down depends on this rate constant.
K
and what I also show you here is that if I,
if I plugged into this equation,
I asked the question,
when does the concentration go down by a factor of two,
when does it go down by 50% I would look on this graph here and say 50% of the
drug has gone by this time.
I could calculate that time at which the drug concentration goes down by half
and that's equal to the natural log of two over k.
This rate constant here.
So when this number is smaller,
the half life is longer,
right?
So molecules with a high k are eliminated rapidly.
Molecules with a low k are eliminated slowly and uh,
and that half life is a good measure of how long the drug activity lasts in your
body.
It's a good way of thinking about how long I'd have to wait before I needed
another dose,
for example.
Okay.
What this graph shows you here is just plotted on a semi log plot.
The difference between these curbs,
if I had drugs with different halflife,
a drug with a half life of 600 minutes lasts a long time,
right?
Concentration doesn't drop until a long time,
as many,
many hours.
If it has a half life of 60 minutes,
concentration drops to 10% of its initial level after a few hours.
And if I have a drug with a half life of six minutes,
concentration drops to 10% of its initial level after only,
uh,
only a few minutes.
And so,
uh,
we're going to take this model and extended next time and talk about more
complicated modes of administration and talk about sort of new forms of drug
delivery,
uh,
forms that you can expect to see in the next,
in the next few years.